la suite de ce 7 8 du 2 octobre avec
l'UNICEF qui recherche des bénévoles et
qui va organiser des portes ouvertes
chaque enfant doit avoir droit à la
santé l'éducation de l'égalité et la
protection c'est le leitmotiv de
l'UNICEF dont la création remonte à 1946
bonsoir Jean-Marie Duprat vous êtes le
délégué du Comité UNICEF dans les
Yvelines vous êtes avec nous ce soir car
l'organisme lance comme chaque année une
campagne pour recruter des bénévoles il
y a des portes ouvertes également qui
vont avoir lieu dans vos locaux ce sera
du 2 aussi octobre aujourd'hui quelle
est la situation est-ce que l'UNICEF sur
la sur la sur le département des
Yvelines dispose d'assez de bénévoles on
ne dispose jamais d'assez le bénévole
voilà j'ai vu tout à l'heure sur un
panneau que l'avenir était à
appartenait à votre à vos collaborateurs
et moi je dis que l'avenir de l'UNICEF
appartient au bénévole de l'UNICEF qui
voudront bien nous rejoindre voilà et
alors qu'est-ce qu'on entend par
recrutement de bénévoles vont servir ces
bénévoles voilà en fait nous avons
besoin des compétences multiples qui
vont depuis être vendeur sur un stand
pour les fêtes de fin d'année pour
vendre des cartes pour ça peut être
rencontrer des villes amis des enfants
pour animer le réseau villa mis des
enfants c'est pour faire du plaidoyer en
milieu scolaire en milieu étudiant
universitaire ça peut être faire
des contacts avec les entreprises qui
peuvent passer des accords de
partenariat avec l'Unicef les offres
sont multiples et ce que nous cherchons
c'est intéressé vraiment les gens à la
cause des enfants dans le monde et
particulièrement dans les Yvelines
puisque c'est un comité important le
quatrième de France et donc s'ils
viennent vers nous on leur fera
découvrir tous cet univers toutes ces
possibilités en fonction de leurs
compétences de leur passion et surtout
de leur disponibilité voilà personne
sont impliquées dans le département des
Yvelines alors nous avons à peu près
150 bénévoles permanents qui font un
petit peu toutes les missions et nous
avons quelques dizaines de bénévoles
dans des métiers très spécialisés et on
va dire une demi-douzaine de postes clés
qui pour faire marcher la boutique pour
faire marcher le comité et sur des
postes à responsabilité mais tout le
monde ne peut pas être bénévole il faut
une fibre forcément bien sûr tout le
monde peut enfin tout le monde peut être
bénévolat sa façon puisque même
aujourd'hui on peut être on peut être y
bénévole on va parler justement
sur le i bénévolat bénévolat en ligne ça
consiste en quoi d'être un il bénévole
c'est les gens qui sont qui pratiquent
internet c'est
se faire l'ambassadeur de la cause des
enfants sur Internet en transmettant des
messages en remplissant des missions par
exemple quelqu'un qui peut rédiger des
documents qui peut rédiger des
communiqués ils peuvent le faire à
distance nous le communiquer et donc il
y a tous les métiers on peut les
retrouver
sur internet sur Internet et donc les
bénévoles peuvent nous relayer dans nos
messages à travers
cette action de y bénévolat qui est
nouveau et ça veut pas dire pour autant
qu'il faut se dispenser d'une visite
dans l'ordre de vos portes ouvertes
à Versailles c'est pas le même type
d'action qui qui sont menés alors
comment ça va se dérouler c'est
porteuses ouvertes justement nous avons
une boutique qui est au 64 rue Royale à
Versailles on a dit la boutique et notre
bureau nous accueillons les bénévoles
ils viennent nous rendre visite on leur
fait découvrir en quelques instants
l'univers de l'UNICEF ce qu'est l'UNICEF
à quoi ça sert sa mission principale
c'est faire du plaidoyer pour la cause
des enfants et récolter des fonds et
leur faire découvrir en fonction enfin
nous nous allons découvrir leur
motivation ce qu'ils ont envie de faire
et après leur proposer j'allais dire des
actions des métiers quand je dis métier
c'est entre parenthèses voilà des
missions sur lesquelles ils vont prendre
beaucoup de bonheur beaucoup de plaisir
à faire alors justement comme cela
concerne les enfants l'UNICEF ça veut
dire que c'est plus facile peut-être
pour recruter justement ces bénévoles il
y a toujours cette fibre cette idée de
se dire on va aider des enfants on est
obligé d'y aller alors
en fait cette fibre elle existe très
très souvent beaucoup chez les gens il
faut mettre en perspective de leur
il faut mettre en perspective ce qu'on
faut leur offrir quelque chose de
concret des missions concrètes qui vont
aimer faire avec leurs compétences et
surtout leur conviction et leur passion
pour la cause des enfants une fois
qu'ils sont convaincus de ça on leur
offre quelque chose à faire d'utile dans
une stratégie bien sûr qui est tout à
fait
qui est bien établi d'avance et on fait
pas n'importe quoi l'UNICEF on va dans
le sens de la mission qui est la nôtre
c'est plaider et récolter des fonds
je prenais ma retraite et je m'étais dit
j'ai envie de faire quelque chose puis
je vois une annonce dans ma bonne ville
de Marly-le-Roi où j'habite on cherche
des bénévoles pour vendre des cartes j'y
suis allé et puis j'ai mis un petit bout
du doigt j'ai mis ça j'ai mis ça j'y ai
trouvé la passion de la cause des
enfants puis j'ai fait un certain nombre
de choses de responsabilité puis
aujourd'hui je vais être le responsable
départemental tout à fait responsable du
comité des Yvelines j'aimerais tout de
même ce que vous êtes sur ce plateau
votre réaction à plusieurs dossiers qui
ont qui ont été cités par l'UNICEF la
porte-parole de l'association Bénédicte
Jeannerot a alerté le gouvernement sur
le démantèlement des camps de Rome et
les conséquences pour les enfants elle
dit que cela va à l'encontre des droits
des enfants c'est votre sentiment
également tout à fait tout à fait
lorsqu'il se alors l'action du ministre
en France est très particulier l'UNICEF
n'a pas mission de n'a pas la même
mission en France que dans les
principalement parlent de l'UNICEF pour
les actions à l'étranger mais l'UNICEF
en France c'est agir auprès des pouvoirs
publics auprès des politiques pour
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
enfants des lois et chaque fois il y a
une situation je vais dire un peu contre
nature par rapport voilà au droit des
enfants l'UNICEF et le premier à réagir
et le leader j'allais dire dans cette
action de protestation ou de réaction
vis-à-vis pour les enfants et cette
situation en France concernant le
démantèlement des camps de Rome c'est
une situation qui vous inquiète tout à
fait oui bien sûr vous serez vigilant
aux mesures qui sont prises ces derniers
temps sur collègues en faveur des
associations l'UNICEF qui a récolté 6
millions d'euros de cette façon en 2011
écoutez monsieur avant de venir nous
avons reçu un mail d'une personne qui
est à l'étranger mais qui a un domicile
dans les Yvelines et qui vient de nous
dire j'ai besoin pour des raisons
familiales X de faire un don à l'Unicef
jour je veux pas vous dire la somme qui
est extrêmement importante comme c'est
quand même très personnel confidentiel
le dossier est déjà traité par notre
siège à Paris pour faire pour pouvoir
bénéficier de ce lac et ça c'est c'est
un métier aussi et là nous recherchons
aussi des gens compétents pour aller
chez les notaires pour s'occuper de
cette démarche parce qu'il y a
énormément de ressources et le
département des Yvelines a un grand
potentiel j'allais dire et de
possibilités et de générosité Jean-Marie
Duprat donc délégué départemental du
comité UNICEF pour le département des
Yvelines porteuse ouverte du 2 au 6 vous
recrutez actuellement des bénévoles et
même des e bénévoles vous expliquer
comment cela fonctionner merci à vous et
puis donc bonne porte ouverte à partir
du 2 octobre la suite de cette édition
qui sera consacrée au sport la page de
sport avec Anthony Reich pour faire le
point sur les derniers résultats locaux